[Music]
so it turns out that Fox News was right
there is a Biden crime family but at the
moment it seems to be limited only to
President Joe Biden's fail son Hunter
Biden yes Hunter Biden has struck a deal
with prosecutors to plead guilty to two
counts of failing to pay taxes in a
timely manner and the president's son
will also complete a pre-trial diversion
program to resolve a felony gun charge
and as part of that plea agreement the
justice department will recommend
probation but a federal judge appointed
by Donald Trump will now have the final
say in the criminal sentence and in a
statement the U.S attorney David Weiss
also a trump appointee said that his
investigation of Hunter is ongoing Joe
Biden said he still loves his son and
Republicans are extremely outraged so
basically there's a little bit for
absolutely everyone to hate in this
particular agreement but is this the
moment that Maga has been waiting for or
just more evidence that Joe Biden has
weaponized the justice department and
what does it mean for the bite
Administration to prosecute both his son
and a political rival at the same time
now the allegations against Hunter Biden
have been investigated on two tracks
political and legal on the the political
side Republicans have accused Hunter of
taking bribes in Ukraine and China
exchange for policy concessions by his
father a Republican Senate committee
investigated Hunter's ties to a
Ukrainian Energy company but did not
identify any policies that were directly
affected by Hunter Biden's work
Republicans have also spent several
years speculating about the contents of
Hunter Biden's laptop it's called the
laptop from L their newest allegation is
that there is a secret document showing
that Hunter and Joe took bribes when Joe
was the vice president now much of the
Chagrin of many of these politicians the
charges here don't have anything to do
with those allegations and as you might
recall in 2018 FBI director Christopher
Ray Who was appointed by Donald Trump
started investigating Hunters overseas
business dealings the FBI serves
subpoenas on hunter in several of his
business associates reportedly looking
for evidence regarding foreign lobbying
money laundering and other crimes the
hunter probe continued under both of
Trump's attorney's General including
Jeff sessions and William Barr and the
political attacks on Hunter intensified
during the 2020 election while the FBI
was continuing the criminal
investigation and after Joe Biden was
elected president he replaced many of
the the U.S attorney is appointed by
Trump however he made an exception for
David Weiss the U.S attorney in Delaware
who was leading the hunter investigation
now presumably Biden thought that it
would appear partisan if he fired the
lawyer who was investigating his son
although Weiss was appointed by Trump
his colleagues described him as a fair
lawyer who wouldn't be swayed bipartisan
interests and Weiss announced criminal
charges on June 20th 2023. Hunter Biden
was charged with two counts of willful
failure to pay income tax and violation
28 USC 7203 and Hunter agreed to plead
guilty to both counts the justice
department also charged Hunter with
possession of a firearm by a person who
was an unlawful user in violation of 18
USC 922 and 924. a hunter Biden agreed
to enter into a pre-trial diversion
program for the firearm violation and
reports suggest that Hunter will be
sentenced to two years of probation
although that will be determined by a
judge according to the sentencing
guidelines now Hunter's lawyer Chris
Clark said quote I know Hunter believes
it is important to take responsibility
for these mistakes he made during a
period of turmoil and addiction in his
life he's looking forward to continuing
his recovery and moving forward forward
Joe Biden issued the statement that
quote the president and first lady loved
their son and support him as he
continues to rebuild his life we will
have no further comment now on the other
side of the aisle some of the
Republicans who had been making hay out
of a potential Hunter Biden prosecution
basically lost their minds Senator Josh
Hawley said quote so Hunter Biden gets a
special plea deal slap on the wrist
probably won't do a day of time while
the doj charges Trump as a spy and tries
to put him in prison forever two
standards of Justice now it's probably
worth pointing out that the doj has not
charged Trump of being a spy nor is it
seeking to put him in jail forever but
let's dig into the hunter Biden charges
now when you buy a firearm you have to
fill out a firearm transaction record
which asks whether you are an unlawful
user or addicted to marijuana or any
depressant stimulant narcotic drug or
any other controlled substance it is
illegal to lie on this form and in 2018
Hunter's then girlfriend who happened to
be his late brother's widow threw his
revolver into a Wilmington trash can a
few days later a man found the revolver
while going through the dumpster the
Secret Service allegedly demanded that
the owner of the gun store where Hunter
bought the gun turnover paperwork
showing that Hunter purchased it and
instead the owner turned the paperwork
over to the ATF according to the
criminal information Hunter purchased
the Colt Cobra 38 Special revolver
sometime in October of 2018. Hunter made
the purchase quote knowing that he was
an unlawful user or addicted to a
controlled substance and when he
completed the Forum Hunter lied about
his history of abusing control of
substance and the statue makes it
illegal for certain people to have
firearms or ammunition the list of
prohibited users includes people who are
drug users or addicts and to prove the
case government just has to show that
the person was using illegal drugs now
Hunter Biden obviously has a long
history of drug addiction and he
admitted to using illegal drugs during
the time of the offense are you smoking
crack around the clock this particular
offense is punishable by up to 10 years
in prison but as my friend scowl has
pointed out many times the amount of
time that someone gets depends on the
federal sentencing guidelines and rarely
gets the maximum here now some are not
happy that the prosecutor here is
recommending pre-trial diversion for
Hunter Biden on the gun charge but this
is a law that many people don't think is
actually constitutional because of the
Supreme Court's interpretation of the
Second Amendment and on top of that it
is a rarely prosecuted crime as one
commentator pointed out the addict in
possession of a weapon charge is very
rarely brought it's been used as a
catch-all for white supremacists in the
past when the feds needed something to
stick and there are several instances
where defendants receive light sentences
like neo-nazis who were sentenced to
time served and a January 6 defendant
who had a big stash of cannabis when
they were arrested and in fact several
federal courts have concluded that
section 922g is unconstitutional because
of the Supreme Court's ruling in the New
York State Rifle and Pistol Association
versus Bruin case after Bruin if the
government wants to put restrictions on
firearm ownership it must quote
affirmatively prove that its firearm
regulation is part of the historical
tradition that delimits the outer bounds
of the right to keep and bear arms now
federal courts have wasted no time in
declaring parts of section 922g
unconstitutional an Oklahoma Federal
court has actually ruled its
unconstitutional to prohibit people who
use illegal drugs from possessing
firearms the government argued that
regulating drug users access to weapons
is quote consistent with a long-standing
historical tradition in America of
disarming presumptively risky persons
namely felons the mentally ill and the
intoxicated but the court disagreed
ruling that the use of marijuana didn't
strip the defendant of his fundamental
right to possess a firearm a Texas
district court also ruled that a
marijuana user could not be prohibited
from accessing a firearm and section 922
G8 bars people with a history of
domestic violence from owning Firearms
but in 2022 the fifth circuit ruled that
people with domestic violence charges
have a Second Amendment right to have
firearms and the three-judge panel wrote
that while it would be probably a good
thing to stop abusers from having
weapons from a historical perspective
the band was an outlier that our
ancestors would never have accepted and
a few other courts have had similar
rulings but most importantly on June 6
2023 the third circuit which includes
Delaware ruled that subsection G1 which
prohibits people with prior convictions
from owning Firearms is unconstitutional
using the same rationale as those other
cases and because of this Bruin case a
domestic violence purp is one of the
people who have a constitutional right
to bear arms and while the government
appealed these decisions the momentum is
on the side of Second Amendment
enthusiasts like Donald Trump Jr and
Hunter Biden so I guess this brings the
Trump and Biden families together in
this case now whether they're drug
related or not devastating injuries and
catastrophic events can happen at any
time and the best time to decide which
lawyer you're going to reach out to when
you or a loved one is injured by someone
else's negligence is today before you're
injured don't wait until the crisis
comes to decide what to do but if you or
a loved one is seriously injured call my
Law Firm the eagle team we can help a
free consultation is just a phone call
away all you have to do is click on the
link down in the description now back to
Hunter Biden on top of the gun charges
Hunter is also being charged with
failure to pay income tax the government
alleges that Hunter Biden allegedly
received more than 1.5 million dollars
in taxable income during 2017 and that
he owed around a hundred thousand
dollars in income taxes Hunter did not
pay the taxes by April of 2018 as
required by federal law and in 2018
Hunter received more than 1.5 million
dollars and failed to pay his taxes by
April 2019. now as a result Hunter
pleaded guilty on two counts of
violating 26 USC's 72 3 which states
quote any person required under this
title to pay any estimated tax or tax
who willfully fails to pay such
estimated tax or tax make such return
keep such records or Supply such
information at the time or times
required by law or regulation shall in
addition to other penalties provided by
law be guilty of a misdemeanor and upon
conviction thereof shall be fine not
more than twenty five thousand one
hundred thousand dollars in the case of
a corporation or imprisonment not more
than one year or both together with the
cost of prosecution and the statute goes
on to say that any willful violation of
that section uh will be a felony rather
than a misdemeanor and the penalty is
five years rather than one years now
Hunter Biden's lawyer told CNN that
Hunter Biden struggled financially
during those years despite making
millions of dollars because of his
addiction and the lawyer said that he
has now fully paid the IRS debts he
didn't timely pay the taxes he was
supposed to pay at the time he
subsequently has paid them and those who
are mad about this case want to know why
Hunter isn't going to get five years in
prison and the answer is pretty simple
prosecutors offered him a deal if he
admitted to guilt and he took that deal
now those lawyers that I've spoken to
who regularly prosecute or defend these
types of crimes indicate that this kind
of plea agreement is nothing out of the
ordinary based on the allegations that
we're seeing and ironically it is the
gun charge that is uh much more unusual
in the sense that it's rarely ever
prosecuted rather than this particular
uh plea agreement based on the tax
charges but some have pointed out that
actor Wesley Snipes got a three-year
sentence for similar tax evasion charges
where Hunter Biden won't spend at night
in jail so what about the Snipes case
well Snipes stop paying all taxes in
1999 quote after coming into contact
with Tax Advisor Eddie Ray Khan of the
tax protest group's American rights
litigators and Guiding Light Of God
Ministries Khan con convinced Snipes
that there was no law imposing taxes on
income earned from U.S sources now this
is a nonsense Sovereign citizen defense
that has repeatedly been debunked by the
IRS and dozens of Courts but Snipes ran
with that argument and took his case to
a trial where a jury found him guilty
and odds are that if Snipes had taken a
plea agreement he probably would have
gotten a much lighter sentence this some
have also criticized Merrick Garland as
going easy on Democratic targets but
also in 2022 Roger Stone settled tax
case with the Department of Justice
where he and his wife owed a whopping 2
million dollars in unpaid taxes but
there Roger Stone was allowed to pay it
off with no probation or charges and
prosecutor David Weiss has already
responded to allegations that Merrick
Garland was calling the shots on the
hunter Biden prosecution in June of 2023
he replied to representative Jim Jordan
by letter saying that Weiss had been
granted quote ultimate authority over
the hunter investigation he also
affirmed his ability to make decisions
without respect to politics quote
throughout my tenure as U.S attorney my
decisions have been made and with
respect to the matter must be made
without reference to political
considerations and Garland himself
commented on the case but didn't say
much quote as I said from the moment of
my appointment as attorney general I
would leave this matter in the hands of
the United States Attorney Who was
appointed by the previous president and
assigned to this matter by the previous
administration he said Weiss was quote
given full authority to decide the
matter as he decided was appropriate and
that's what he's done now the hunter
Biden crime Saga is a complex and
nuanced case which makes it ripe for
politization now news outlets covering
the trial can shape people's
understanding of the issues depending on
the details they focus on and the
language they use which is why I'm
excited about today's sponsor ground
news ground news is a great website and
app that lets you compare related
articles in one place from thousands of
sources from around the world and across
the political Spectrum with context
about the source of the information for
example the big story about Hunter Biden
pleading guilty was covered widely by
431 news outlets across the political
Spectrum but it really gets interesting
when you compare these headlines
left-leaning articles referred to
misdemeanor tax charges while news
outlets on the right refer to it as a
sweetheart deal and both types of
sources kept the actual charges vague so
you definitely want to click through and
read the entire article but ground news
digs in with every story and shows that
not all of them are evenly reported for
example the story about a whistleblower
testimony released by The GOP was mostly
covered by news outlets on the right and
meanwhile the story about Donald Trump
referring to his prosecution as a
traffic ticket was mostly covered by the
left and if you look at the factuality
ratings for both of these stories it's
not super high and you'll want to read
with caution and this is just a taste of
why ground news is a fascinating and
useful way to read the news and why it's
unlike any other news site out there so
if you want to give it a try you can use
my link and get 30 off their all access
Vantage subscription just click on the
link that's on screen right now or down
in the description you'll help out
independent and transparent news and if
you click on the link below you'll get
30 off after that click on this link
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court